americanized chinese dishes like orange
chicken
general sews right those are those
aren't like real chinese dishes those
are just
those were created in america for the
white man
right and but the reason why they did
that is because
it comes from a business standpoint
right like i got to stay in business so
i got to feed the museums
i got to be able to sell this food and
the only people around me are all white
so they're i got to make sure it fits
their palette
yeah right nothing wrong with like fried
chicken like dunked in orange sauce
right and so
you know that's how those dishes came
about but then you look at all these
but like chinese food is only one that
has that but you look at
other cuisines like vietnamese korean
japanese in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
i have a very very special guest here
today uh
chef extraordinaire i want you to
introduce yourself today
hello everybody um my name is matt ewan
i have been working professionally as a
chef now for
the past eight years um been working
in some pretty cool kitchens such as
luxon spago
uh now i'm at i'm the chef the cuisine
at riot games so i'll help oversee their
food program
and you know make sure they get fed yeah
every day
i mean i think uh i've been bringing a
couple of chef people on like i
mentioned before we started this podcast
but oh i'm gonna burp real quick
oh there it is um
but i feel food is something that's been
expanding so fast lately
um in terms of not just like restaurant
but just the scene alone
in terms of entertainment you see it
over on instagram twitter and everything
else like that
and one of the biggest things that uh
specifically i know a lot of people
message me about they go well i want to
be in food too how do i do that
i don't really know how to answer that
because i do branding and marketing for
a lot of food spots and
you know every now and then i'll do you
know r d on some type of food
yeah but it's it's not to like a
restaurant level
because i don't know what that involves
per se i just know i've seen the back
of when you were working at luxon and i
was like hell no
oh hell no dude it's so difficult it's
different
you know it's like because for me i i
made a career change
when i was like 27 right so i was in
sales
when i was 18 to like 27 and i decided
you know what
i don't mean sales anymore and i decided
that you know i've always had this like
desire to cook right and i think a lot
of people have like this
urge you know because they have this
interest and hobby that they have in the
kitchen
or at home and they cook for their
friends and they make these amazing
meals and all their friends tell them
hey
you should become a chef and i'm you
know i had the same thing i had a bunch
of friends that tell me that
but i knew that i had to really dive all
the way in
right yeah yeah like you have to really
get in there and
see it for yourself what it's really
like before you can make the decision
and go and open a restaurant
right and so for me it's like you know i
i made a decision i committed fully to
it i went to culinary school
and while i was working in all going to
culinary school
[Music]
i was i worked as a dishwasher right and
so i did everything
from like the ground all the way up
right so i'd you know work from
every position in the in the back of the
house in the kitchen
right and then finally you know i was
able to become a sous chef
at luxon um and then
yeah i mean it's it's totally different
like you it's
it's not what you think it really is
yeah right
like you just have no idea to actually
get in there and it's
it's so much harder than it and actually
you actually see it on tv
it's it's ten times harder than it
actually is when you're actually doing
it on a day-to-day basis
on tv it looks [ __ ] hard dude
it's harder than that yeah well i think
also too because you you
you definitely went into the more
high-end restaurants right um
what's like the day-to-day like when you
first started i mean obviously as a
dishwasher but let's say you become
uh a sous chef what are your
responsibilities it i guess
it depends on the restaurant you know it
depends on where you're at but for the
most part
you know you're in a leadership role
right and so at luxon
you know i was pretty much like the main
guy in charge at that point
right and so i had um about 10 other
people that i was overseeing
and you know i just made sure everything
ran smoothly on a day-to-day basis
i did some of the um r d to help come up
with new dishes
um you know i managed the numbers you
know making sure that you know the labor
cost and food cost was
you know in check um and
at that point once you move into like a
leadership position in the kitchen
it's a lot less about the cooking right
people
still think that you know you're
supposed to be behind the line cooking
these
you know everything for the for the
restaurant but it's not so much the case
anymore
it's like it's just like in any
leadership position you're
it's more about the people now than it
is it is
actually about the cooking right so for
me it was
80 management now and then 20 actually
cooking
right i spent more time like making sure
um you know more time like doing
research and development and
and and uh behind a computer a lot of
times
yeah yeah right like you you don't
at first like this is what i signed up
for i thought i was gonna be behind the
kitchen or in the
in the kitchen cooking you know
everything um but
no you gotta be able to learn how to
manage others and
and especially in the kitchen you you
have so many different
types of people right the dynamic is you
know a lot of times you know
these people are um
they come from rough backgrounds you
know and some a lot of them are
immigrants
and a lot of them um you know some don't
really speak any english
you know you get admit like a whole
mismatch of just people
and you've got to learn how to manage
them you know people managing is
probably the the hardest part right
yeah and i think that just comes with
with any business and that's not
something that
i think a lot of people understand
before their business starts to grow
right and then right when you have to
get into this position where i'm like
okay
these aren't just people these are 30
different personalities right how do i
speak to them
how do i manage them because everybody
it's even like in relationships personal
relationships
you don't talk to every single one of
your friends the same way right
you speak to them to how they
communicate how they interpret things
and you have to do that with like 30
employees i'm like
how the [ __ ] do i do this you know it's
[ __ ] i i think it's damn near
impossible sometimes you know
it's tough you know now at riot games i
have like
35 40 cooks that i oversee
you know there's like a total of like 90
plus employees on our side
wow and i i oversee most of the cooks
and i work with them on a daily basis
and
yeah that's that's 35 40 different
personalities
yeah right and every single one of them
i talk to
in like a different way yeah right i
can't approach
the guy that is in his 50s who's much
older than me
the same way i approached the kid that's
like 22.
yeah right it's it you have to figure
out that dynamic
i think you know i'm i'm
i'm lucky the fact that i have this
experience being in sales and i was in
management before
i made this career change and so i can
take that i can bring that to the table
you know um a lot of times most chefs
you know they don't have that that
management experience right and they
kind of learn as they go
and it's a lot tougher yeah and it takes
it that's why it takes
sometimes like certain cooks a long time
to make that transition from being just
a good cook
to being a sous chef right because you
have to have that
that leadership skill that you can't
really
it's hard to learn in a kitchen right
and so you know now being a chef at riot
games
is it's like now it's like a lot less
cooking i'm it's more like 90 percent
management
like 10 cooking so um
do you think um cooking is something
that everybody can learn or do you think
that
you people need a certain amount of
talent and a certain palette to know how
to develop a dish
i think anybody can cook right i think
everybody
should learn how to cook and i think
it's not like because cooking is a
technique
right it just comes down it boils down
to really the technique first and you
learn the skill of having how to like
grill something how to sear
how to braise something that all can be
taught right
um it just depends on how well of a list
how good of a student you are
right and then as far as like how good
your
your food tastes that's gonna take some
like talent
right that's where the your palate and
understanding
food comes into play right yeah but for
the most part everybody can
i mean you can make it decent you can
learn to make a decent meal anybody can
do that right i mean i've seen because
uh i mentioned this with
uh chef chris oh and i was telling him
how when i
i did this netflix show where i was a
food judge right
and it was interesting because
because of the accessibility of of
cooking shows on youtube and everything
else i think
and this was just something i was
thinking to myself how sometimes i think
people are
they're they're they have so many things
they want to put on to one dish right
and then you
but it doesn't come out to one good bite
yeah you know it becomes too much and
like i saw that a lot on the show where
i could tell that they saw this
technique here they saw this
ingredient somewhere else and they're
like this is going to be great in this
dish
but when i ate it i'm like i could
already tell before they put out like
don't please don't put that on
you know because it's too much right and
so it's all these strong flavors or
whatever else these influences that they
have on this one morsel and you put in
your mouth and it tastes like nothing
right you know right and i think people
get a little too excited
and i wish and i just kind of saw this
to myself when i started trying to cook
a little more at home
was that i was like okay well let's
let's just start with something that i
know very well right that's something
that's
already keen that i'm already keen to
which is korean food yeah so once
i was like don't try to do italian don't
try to do any of this right just do
korean if you can get this right
then we'll we'll go somewhere else after
yeah and i think that helped me out a
lot because i
at least understood these ingredients
yeah you know yeah and i think that was
that was totally the case
it really through the case for like any
young cook right anybody that
is um starting out and learning how to
like
write a menu item and i had that same
struggle when i was a lakshan like
i would pitch all these like ideas to
you know to saying and he would just
like tear them apart
right and um but i didn't you know at
first i didn't understand it but once
i've you know once he's mentioned one
team mentored me
i understood that you have to just kind
of edit it you know and
and a lot of times when you're young you
don't have somebody there
to edit your your work
right it's you get this like mess of
like techniques and flavors because you
want to try everything you want to try
to impress people
and you try to like do too much right
when
it's really about stripping away rather
than
adding more stuff to it right and so the
it's it also comes with like the
maturity
and your in your um and the confidence
that you have
because when you're a new cook like a
lot of times
you don't have that confidence yet of
like making a good dish
you don't have the confidence of like
the right techniques
so you try to do too much you try to do
everything to impress other people
but then the better cook you become the
better chef you become
you know now it's more about how can i
do how can i make a dish with less
ingredients in it
and still make it taste really really
good oh that's so it's funny i
i literally thought about that maybe
like a year ago and
when you know when you're at home and
you're cooking all these things and
you're looking at other people's recipes
online right and then i
i really started doubting some of these
recipes because i'm like do you need
these 36 spices like can you can you
actually taste it
and so i started modifying it myself and
i really started doing that where i was
taking certain things that i
when i made it the the first way i tried
somebody's recipe and i ate it i'm like
i can't taste half of this [ __ ] so what
is what in here is necessary or what is
it
and i feel like sometimes when people
see that and they're trying to innovate
a recipe they go i'm just gonna add more
to this
to say that it's my recipe yeah and i
started seeing that in a lot of these
like online youtube recipes i'm like
i know for a fact that you can't taste
that [ __ ]
you know they do like this fried chicken
recipe and it's like two cups of flour
and they put a half a teaspoon of ginger
why
you're not tasting that a hundred
percent right and so i'm i started
buying all these extra spices and
ingredients
and i think i started kind of believing
into that hype where i was like oh
do i do this in my food too do i just
add stuff just to say it's different
yeah you just gotta strip it away we
used to call it um
we just call it flies [ __ ] because
like you you never see in nature you
can't see
you know yeah flies like fornicating but
yeah you know it's like if you can't see
it then it shouldn't be
there right so like the food it's like
you know do you have all this stuff in
there is it just flies [ __ ] or is it
like really neat does it really need to
be there
right can you even see it i can even
tell that it's there right
i think one of my like some of my
favorite restaurants too it's just
uh they they do a very specific dishes
very well
you know like din tai fung tai fung the
xiaolong bells are so
good yeah you know when i go there i'm
not they don't have
like 86 different flavors it's kind of
it is what it is
and they execute it so well yeah and
it's it's a dish that
a thousand other places make but for
some reason they just do it that much
better
right and when people ask me i had a
buddy of mine named billy
he was coming over to la and he goes yo
i want to try some of the best like
xiaolongbaos here right i'll say
you guys have you tried din tai fung and
they're like yeah i'm like
all right i i mean there are other
places that do
there's a place out in pasadena and i
think he was a chef from din tai fung
dan's modern and i think he he just put
his own little twist to it but when they
have his dumplings it tastes just like
yeah it's probably the same yeah i was
like
this is the same as this you know i
think that's the cool thing
too where you're talking about when you
strip away you do something really
really well
and a lot of the dishes that i
personally like are are a lot more
simple than it is more complicated yeah
it just doesn't need to have all
these belts and whistles a lot of times
yeah so but anyway that's just how it is
when you're when you're
you know again like you're not um you
don't have the confidence level yet you
know you're trying to just do too much
when you when you were 27 and you what
were you doing before
i was in sales so i sold
i sold knives oh i got a connection yeah
what time was yourself so i was selling
a brand called cutco oh cutco yeah yeah
yeah
i remember cutco back in the day when
they were doing door-to-door sales with
people
yeah right so i was like i got a
recruiter when i was 18
right out of high school and i did that
all throughout my my first summer out of
high school into college
paid my way through college with it
learned learned how to like
make cold calls and you know and
really develop my communication skills
and and
um got some management experience and i
think
when i graduated college there wasn't
much of a you know it was 2000
when i graduated so right before a
recession and so the job market was
looking really slim
and this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare are you that type of person
that wants to start or explore a passion
but you don't think you have the time or
maybe you don't even know where to start
that's where skillshare comes in
skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes to help you explore
new skills
and learn things on your own time and
schedule listen
there are a lot of things that i want to
do and learn and skillshare actually has
a dope amount of classes that i can
learn online
the classes are endless and if you're
someone like me that loves learning
things on their own time
this is what you really do need to get
right now i'm actually doing a course
called
filmmaking from home and the tips that i
use from it i actually still use it in
my videos
learning is such a process and everybody
learns on on their own pace and
honestly because they have such a huge
library i can pick and choose everything
that i want to learn and it's something
that i really enjoy
i feel a lot of the times people don't
like learning because they're not doing
it at their own pace
and skillshare just has these courses
that you can pick and choose from all
the time and it's something that i
personally
really really do love so explore your
creativity and get
two free months of premium membership at
skillshare.combrain
that's two whole months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
get started and join today by heading to
skillshare.com brain that's two free
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes at skillshare.com
they offered me a district manager
position so i took it oh wow
and so i did that for another five years
and then i just got
burnt out and and realized i didn't want
to do it for
the next five years so i was like you
know what i just gotta close up shop and
then
um yeah move back move back to my
parents
and and try to figure out what i wanted
to do next
and that was when i decided you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna cook
so i think the turning point really was
um the conversation with my my grandma
you know because you know when i moved
back home
my grandma was she she was
pretty ill and we knew that her time was
you know coming to an end and
and you know we you know i had a
conversation with her
and she i think she saw the struggle
that i was having right and she
can feel it and she grandma's just have
that sense and yeah
and she just told me um you know what
do what you love and you know and i
think she
was kind of hinting the fact that you
know she always knew that i loved to
cook
you know i've been cooking by her side
since i was like eight years old
so she was like just kind of pushing me
in that direction and i just
decided you know what i i'm gonna go and
do it i'm just gonna
just dive right in i'm i'm only 27
and i was like i might as well do it now
rather than later
and i think one of the conversations i
had with one of my friends is
you know she told me um are you gonna
regret
you know not making this decision or are
you gonna
rig you know are you gonna you know five
years down the line are you gonna regret
not making this the decision to go and
cook or
are you gonna are you gonna regret not
making it at all right
so you know and that ultimately just
said you know i'm just gonna go and do
this
there's nothing i can lose you know so
um
now it's been eight years now since this
that's in that point and
you know i'm really happy doing what i
love you know i think
a lot of people you know they have they
can't
they they struggle finding something
they enjoy doing
and you know i was very passionate about
cooking and that's why i just you know
made this career change and went for it
was that was that a very scary feeling
for you
oh absolutely you know especially with
you know being
chinese-american like your your
parents they they they want you to like
they don't want you to become a cook
right that's like that's like the
the bottom of the totem pole yeah right
that's what we had to do when we got
here type of thing
why would you do it yeah like they they
wanted better for you right and so
um you know they wanted me to become a
doctor or a lawyer or an accountant like
it was like
becoming a chef was like it's like
shunned almost right
and it's it take it took a lot of time
before my my parents were convinced that
this was something that i would
excel at right i think you know a lot of
it was
when um i think i did a pop-up
once i did a pop-up um right when i was
still in culinary school
really early in my my cooking cooking
career
and i did this pop-up i negotiated with
this like
bakery owner to let me use their kitchen
at night and
hold a pop-up for like 40 people and i
made
i made the deal happen and you know they
got a piece of the pie and
and uh i just had people come and just
showed up
it was kind of amazing my parents were
kind of impressed with the fact that i
did something like that
um and then i think you know once they
saw me you know how hard
i worked that in and you know
all the progression that i've made in
the last few years and now
you know being in the chef cuisine over
at riot i think they're
they're happy and they're glad that i
made this decision
um which is which is great so yeah yeah
food is so it's gone through such a huge
transformation i think in the in in the
recent years you know
and i i think what i really liked too
was you know is what
jonathan gold kind of added into the
scene of food right it was
that whole concept of you know we we
only thought amazing food could be at a
fine dining restaurant
right and when jonathan gold were he was
giving out his jonathan gold stars to
these places like
mariscos jalisco right and some of these
like sichuan restaurants out in the sgv
it kind of opened up a conversation
about what amazing food can be
you know and even for me too and i think
because i grew up watching
all this food network stuff and you know
pbs and all this like free touch about
food
they would only talk about restaurants
like french laundry or whatever what not
right
and in my mind i was being fed this
thing of like only that can be amazing
food if it has a high price tag
and i remember when i came to la and
there was like these a lot of aha
moments i had with foods i was like
damn [ __ ] mexican food is insane here
you know i was like what is this
taco right you know and i because my
perception it was
a mexican food was a fat huge wet
burrito that was just stuffed down my
face and i'm like this is some good
mexican food
and then i remember just going to these
little taco spots and all these other
little joints and i'm like this is
this is amazing and when i was going to
muddy's closed hales i was eating it
i didn't even know jonathan gold went
there but it was like that that tacos
dorado that they served
it's like this is so [ __ ] good one of
the best things in l.a yeah and then i
saw this little
jonathan i was like what the [ __ ] this
is nuts you know but it was kind of cool
what he was doing man and i really
appreciated that
especially because he showed a lot of
love to asian cuisine yeah
i think he showed a lot of love to all
the mom and pops yeah right and just
kind of
put people put the spotlight on on the
ones that normally don't get a spotlight
right and you know we have so many
amazing amazing restaurants in l.a
um and it's not just about fine dining i
mean this the fine dining in l.a didn't
really
you know hit it i mean it's really hit
his peak in the last couple of years
where you have like these
amazing tasting menus now um
but before that and like you know 10 or
10 years ago
it wasn't really the case right you have
most of la's food
dining scene is like mom and pop you
think about thing about k-town
right all those amazing like you know
just mom-and-pop
you know korean spots you know same
thing with suv and all these other
like all these neighborhoods all these
ethnic neighborhoods that we have here
that make la great is just all this
amazing amazing food
i think he did an amazing job like
highlighting all of that i think what la
does really well in terms of food
because there's like a few food mecca
that they talk about in the united
states right san francisco uh la and new
york
i think the biggest thing that la offers
is i won't say like the word is
authenticity but they
if a korean restaurant serves something
that's what they're gonna serve
you know it doesn't matter if if there's
a seasonal vegetable around
it's not going to be on the menu right
so they if you
want that like you want i don't know
kanjitang from a very specific place
that's what they're going to serve just
because winter came around or summer
came around you're not going to find
[ __ ] some seasonal vegetable beets or
some [ __ ] in there you know
but i think that's what that's i guess
like that's what i
i don't see if i like or dislike this in
new york but it's some of the places
just started tasting pretty much the
same yeah because i kept on seeing
the repetitive stuff because they want
to keep seasonal vegetables all of their
stuff and i'm like
but this is a japanese restaurant you
know i don't want ramps here
right you know right so uh i mean i
think the food in new york is really
amazing but i think i appreciated that
about la is that if you wanted that
quote-unquote authentic food experience
that
something that they were good at they're
going to have that right it's not going
to change it's like
you can find almost anything you want
here in l.a right
it's this yeah yeah you can go you know
you can drive across town and then
they might actually you'll never be able
to taste every go to every single
restaurant in that lake
that's almost impossible it's like oh
it's it's damn near impossible
right so but you have so many different
ethnic groups there's so many
corners of la that you know have this
amazing food and it kind of
it's tough now because obviously with
coveted and everything but like a lot of
these mom-and-pop shops are all closing
right which is scary because you you
lose
like this um the story you know in l.a
right and like you think about
especially in k-town i see a lot of
these
these like places that do the specific
dish
right that are going to just disappear
and
the kids aren't going to take over
because again it goes back to the
america you know the
asian american story of like i don't
want my kids to own a restaurant right
yeah so you know you're going to lose
this amazing history
of like of food and that's kind of scary
to me right now
especially the whole restaurant scene
and just places
just shutting down yeah that's that's
interesting because that is a very f i
never really thought about that too
because
there's i think our generation is very
unique right we're we're in this point
where
the next generation there aren't going
to be as much first-gen immigrants
right right so they would they take over
their parents restaurants i don't i
don't know
and if they don't who's who's gonna
who's gonna serve that food yeah you
know
i i i never really thought about that
[ __ ] a lot of the stuff that we're
experiencing now maybe the next
generation won't even get to have
exactly oh [ __ ] exactly well now i'm
depressed
yeah because you just don't have that
same that same immigration coming in
yeah you know and the reason why these
people came you know they wanted
you know better life for themselves but
they opened up restaurants because that
was
the only thing they knew how to do yeah
right now it's totally different now you
have this next generation
and and yeah like i said they they don't
want their kids to become restaurant
owners yeah
and because owning a restaurant is like
one of the toughest things you can do
that's true it's it's uh and some of my
favorite korean restaurants too and
there are other korean restaurants that
are opening up now but i think
um some these restaurants i don't really
like to go to as much
because i feel like they are trying to
americanize their food too much to the
point where it doesn't taste like the
original food anymore yeah like i don't
know how many times korean people can
melt cheese over something
right you know it's like i don't need it
like if i want to melt i'll go get a
[ __ ] pizza yeah
you don't need another korean gastropod
exactly
in koreatown and every time something
new opens up it's like hey
we're going to melt cheese on this and
i'm like i i don't need that
you know yeah you need you need like the
the soulful
like home-cooked type meal from like for
sure
like you're a true korean mother yeah
it's something that's very
very difficult to replicate you know
because they do something
very unique very well and that's
starting to i think disappear sometimes
because people want the
instagramable photo right right which is
why you see a string cheese
pull everywhere yeah
you know i saw this video on instagram
the other day it was a burger
right they stuck a knife through it and
then they they dumped like
i don't know like a pound of just fondue
cheese all over it and they had a steak
on top of it and i'm like who the [ __ ]
would eat that
who the [ __ ] is gonna eat that you know
it's gonna get like a million likes
yeah and it has like a million [ __ ]
views on it and i'm looking at it
and people are like drool i was like
would you really eat that
you know like and this is i'm still a
pretty fat guy
i don't want that i don't look at that
and say that is appetizing
yeah right you know so i don't
understand and
it's it's very sad and kind of
exploitive of what food can be you know
um how about smug i mean i i eat
mcdonald's regularly you know i still
like my shoes
yeah you know what i mean i eat
mcdonald's i eat all my junk food you
know one of my favorite joints that i
still eat to this day is the hat the
pastrami sandwich joint
i [ __ ] love that spot like uh just
because i eat great food doesn't mean
that that's the food i choose to eat
most of the time
but that's like more on the every now
and then my everyday food is
is nuts so i know there is like this new
like amazing pastrami place that opened
in west adams in la called johnny's
really good
so good so good they smoked their
pastrami in-house
and you know they have like you got your
pastrami rubens your
your thinly sliced pastrami sandwiches
you got like pastrami burnt ends
oh wow have you been to uh have you
tried this spot that was out in
smorgasbord called ugly drum
i have not no so he was he was the i
from what i remember from the
conversation i had with him he used to
smoke all the briskets for blood cells
and he did his own thing now but i
wonder if because i had that sandwich
and i was like this is [ __ ] good
because he smoked this pastrami
just like he did the the brisket over at
bloodstose and he also had the burnt end
stuff too and i was kind of when i ate
it i was like oh [ __ ] this is
this is better than language dude people
were like is it really
i was like it's substantially better
when it's smoked
you know it's something else right you
know it's completely different
it's so [ __ ] good what's that place
called again johnny's johnny's okay
i guess so the the chef there um he has
another spot
called mizlala on west adams and
johnny's used to be it used to be a
pastrami just like a an old pashami
restaurant there
on west adams but then closed down he
went in there and just revamped the
whole thing
oh [ __ ] yeah it's dope and see and those
are the spots too that once again they
specialize on something yeah
really really good and that's it yeah
it's it's amazing
yeah i've i've definitely found out like
um just if i went down a list of
everything that i like it's always a
restaurant with one or two great things
you know and they're like what about
this stuff on the menu i was like i got
no [ __ ] clue i don't go there for
that
right you don't need a restaurant with
like 30 menu items yeah that's what
those hong kong style cafes like they
have so much [ __ ]
i don't know like everything under the
sun
they want to appeal to everybody that
walks through the door they have grilled
cheese sandwiches
french fries they have all this other
[ __ ] then you have like hong kong style
like fried noodle i'm like what is going
on i don't understand what the [ __ ] i'm
supposed to order here
how the [ __ ] do they stay open like you
know yeah
i used to i used to go there a lot as a
kid like those are like
those are the spots those are the spots
you know there was also spots after like
going to the club and then yeah they're
still open till like 4 a.m
was it was the one that i used it was a
tasty garden i used to always go to
there's like a few of those spots
there's like one
and uh a guy when i was like 280 pounds
dog that's the spot that i would go to
number one it's very inexpensive yeah
like
it's super cheap it doesn't even make
sense why it's like how can it be that
inexpensive like you're not making like
where are you getting this chicken from
like
why is this so cheap like are they just
like breeding them themselves like i
don't understand
it's you could buy food for like six
people for like
58 bucks yeah you know that's ridiculous
and then you'll have leftovers
yeah right i remember uh just like
having i didn't know like
what hong kong style cafes were you know
and uh
the food is actually very unique just
from regular chinese food that you have
yeah it's like this it's that that
british or american influence in the
food
right and when i first looked at the
menu i was like is this what is this
you know like i remember i had the
tomato pork chop over
rice and i was like it's one of my
favorite dishes like the [ __ ] is this
disgusting looking thing
and i bit into it i'm like damn this is
[ __ ] good
yeah it looked like some drunk person
just went to the back and made whatever
the [ __ ] they want and they put it on a
dish it's small and pretty much it's
like
you think about where it comes from
right again it is like that british
influence
it's like chinese people trying to
please the white palette
so there's like a classic this podcast
is brought to you by
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or maybe
you realize that your mental health
just needs a boost or it's something you
haven't really focused on in your life
see this year especially since we've
been cooped up with limited social
interactions we really need to check
in on our mental health i will always
say this
but just to say it again your mental
well-being is as important as your
physical well-being
for those of you who don't know better
help is great because they can match you
with your own professional license
therapist
you can schedule your sessions via phone
communicate a message online do video
calls and you can even change your
counselors
if needed if you're at home and you want
to try online counseling give this a try
please i love it and you can too if you
want to give this a try
geniusbrainlisteners i got the hookup to
get 10 off your first
month of better help just type in
betterhelp.com
genius to get that offer today once
again that's b
e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash genius the most classic
british
and like hong kong influenced dish is uh
macaroni noodles uh macaroni soup
with like ham or like spam
yeah what the [ __ ] is that so that's
what that fried egg
like that yeah i always saw that on the
menu and i'm like it's like a hong kong
like
comfort food like it's just like it's
literally just like chicken broth some
elbow macaroni
some cut up ham or spam if you got it in
a fried egg
and that's like your breakfast item and
so it's just weird it's just again it's
like it comes from like
being colonized you know you have these
random ingredients let's just make
something and
please this new crowd whenever i saw
that on the menu i i had no idea i
thought that was just some [ __ ]
drunken mistake
it probably wasn't i didn't know that
that was like a hong kong style staple
dish
yeah it's an absolute like comfort food
like i remember eating it as a kid
you know and so my mom would make it for
me at home and
and when you go to hong kong you go to
these places called uh
cha chang cha chang tang um
and you get this type of food you get
that you get like a
pineapple bun there you'll get like like
peanut butter stuffed french toast
what the [ __ ] yeah nuts yeah and then
you have like your
your kanji and then you also have like
this whole mishmash of like random stuff
yeah and it's it's just like part of the
of uh hong kong breakfast
yeah yeah the um i also asked like chef
chris about this stuff too but uh
uh i i think like food has become such a
touchy subject for a lot of people
especially
when it comes to like white people
making asian food right
and i'm always like back and forth on
this type of stuff
only because i feel like a lot of the
food that i
partake in is there is fusion food
right so for example i use this example
before like uh like peruvian food yeah
that's
that's asian food and you know like
southwest all mixed into one yeah you
know so there's like this beauty of
people kind of partaking into certain
dishes like i read this tweet the other
day where somebody was like
if you don't like fish sauce don't try
to uh
don't try to like anglicize it just to
make it sure that somebody could
uh like it for the palette you know or
whatever what not right
and for me i had a little bit of an
issue with that um and a lot of people
under that comment were saying like
yeah if you don't want to have just
don't have it at all and i'm like well
where's the conversation happening here
right because
let's be real fish sauce smells like
[ __ ] yeah it's it's fermented fish cuts
it's terrible yeah you know and if i had
something that i wanted somebody to try
because they never had it before
i think i would like to give them a
segue into maybe
trying it later in the future right
without just giving them putrid fish
water
right you're not going to like spoon
feed somebody like fish
yeah so like for me i i i'm trying to
understand where that comment i think it
just comes from you know once again when
you were a kid and
you you had this asian food and people
used to make fun of you for it
and now you're having this pride of like
oh i can be proud and be asian and i
don't
want to change my dish to serve somebody
else's palate which i understand
right but at the same time i still want
people to understand our food and try it
out
because i think breaking bread is a huge
way for people to connect absolutely
absolutely i think i think it comes from
like what area you're from too
right like now i think people are much
more open to it than
like 50 years ago oh for sure right
especially with chinese food like
like chinese food in america has is
made to fit the white palette right like
you think about the most um americanized
chinese dishes like
orange chicken general sews right those
are
those aren't like real chinese dishes
those are just those were
created in america for the white man
right and but the reason why they did
that is because
it comes from a business standpoint
right like i gotta stay in business so i
gotta feed these
i gotta be able to sell this food and
the only people around me are all white
so they're i gotta make sure it fits
their palate
yeah right nothing wrong with like fried
chicken like dunked in orange sauce
right and so
you know that's how those dishes came
about but then you look at all these
but like chinese food is only one that
has that but you look at
other cuisines like vietnamese korean
japanese a lot of times it hasn't been
like dumbed down
to like be able to fit that you know fit
the pallet of of somebody else
right like you it's it's not like like
it's not apologetic at all
it's yeah you know you have you go to a
korean restaurant it's
it's a korean restaurant it's not like
you're not
you're not getting the specific dish
that's been made here in america
that you can't really be able to get in
korea per se
that's true right oops then i didn't
really think about that [ __ ] yeah that's
that is very true yeah i i think like
that space too where that
um that chinese american food came in
like that space is
i i always hate this conversation that i
have with people when
i like one of my favorite chinese
american restaurants is this place
called yang chaos out in
chinatown they have this thing called
slippery shrimp you know
it's so [ __ ] good right you know and
then sometimes i i
have conversations with other asian
americans and they're just like that's
not real chinese food and i'm like i
i don't know what that means you know
i'm just saying i'm eating the food
because i like right
it tastes like i'm like the same way
like i'll i know i have some people that
will be like i ain't real chinese food
but like i know
in my heart there's a little tiny little
space for like orange chicken
like you're not you're not going to tell
me i'm not going to eat this orange
chicken like
a little bit of my chinese hood like
disappears when i eat it but i still
love it
like that slippery shrimp thing i'm like
the [ __ ] is this i'm like this is
[ __ ] delicious that place has been
like a chinese american staple it's that
fried rice with the peas the carrots and
all this other stuff and when i eat it
i'm like
yeah the fried rice at maybe like uh an
authentic chinese it's gonna taste
better for sure
but i still have space for this i still
like this
right you know it tastes good yeah it
tastes [ __ ] good
right like why why should i have to
apologize for liking the stuff that i
grew up with because
now you you're true you found this this
gusto to be
hardcore you know asian and now i can't
enjoy the stuff that i grew up with like
i'm suddenly a traitor
you know i feel odd you know yeah and i
think food doesn't i don't think food
should have that i think food
i do understand um when people don't
like it when let's say
how much you can use white people like a
white person comes in and tells you how
to eat your asian food it bothers me a
little bit
especially when they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about right right
but at the same time there's a lot of
like
this fusion stuff that has happened here
that i personally do enjoy
i think as long as the uh in terms of
authenticity of
that story of how that person made that
dish is fine i'm okay with it like that
let's say a chef went to korea he lived
in korea his wife's korean he opened up
a korean restaurant it tastes [ __ ]
good
i got no problem i'm going to eat his
food
it tastes good he did his due diligence
you know i can't be mad at him for that
right
yeah just as long as not some somebody
just throwing gochujang on
which doesn't which i get it you know
that does happen a lot right yeah and um
there was this video on twitter and that
went viral because
there's this guy that was like i'm gonna
teach you how to make fun and that [ __ ]
looks so bad
you know and he just like his phone
noodles were all brown and i was like
what the [ __ ] what is that
what is this thing you know and people
ask me like you should roast this guy
he's like i'm not gonna roast him
if he if he likes to eat his [ __ ] i bet
then you know god be with you
you know yeah but i don't think he's
doing anything wrong per se he's not
telling you like
this is how far should be he's just
making his garbage version
this is my version of it yeah it just
sucks but
yeah it sucks but if he wants to eat it
you whatever goes in your mouth
and you [ __ ] it out that's on you you
know god be with you
right you know and sometimes i always
tell that to people with like when uh
like oh how do you make this and i'm
like oh [ __ ] i don't really know because
i do it like my mom does it
you know i just kind of toss [ __ ] around
throw a bunch of stuff like i'm not a
professional chef i don't i don't know
what to tell you
you know yeah and um sometimes when
people make their food like should it
taste like this and i always say this
do you like it and they go yes that's
all that matters right
because you're eating it i'm not eating
it i can't tell you it tastes bad when
you think it tastes delicious
you know you're not serving it to the
public right you know it's home food
yeah and that's the thing i met i've
been working a lot of like
so i'm working out working from home
right in the last you know
now five months and and in the last
month or so i've been like making these
uh really simple um
30 30-minute meals for like these home
cooks and that's the thing with like
cooking at home
it it shouldn't be like super precise
right like you don't need to like
measure everything you know as long as
it like
makes sense and it comes out tasting
good you're you're
good right it should be fine right and
so
um i think a lot of times people when
they start learning how to cook they're
like they're so concerned about making
sure that
you you really put in two tablespoons of
this or
one cup of this and it's like you you
again you lose the technique
right you're so good at following these
instructions but
you know cooking is more becomes it
should be more instinctual
right and you should like learn what the
basic technique of the dish dishes and
what the basic flavor should be and then
that way you can replicate or use that
technique for something else
you know right i think i only recently
probably started doing that
like well for example i i started making
like korean mandus at home right yeah
and then i asked my mom how she made it
and then i was like [ __ ] that
and i was like you gave me the general
idea right and so i just made it for a
bunch of friends the other day and they
were like oh how do you make these
dumplings i'm like
don't worry we're just gonna eat it just
do it however you like it doesn't have
to be as pretty as mine
we're just gonna eat it it's fine and so
like if i gave that dumpling to my mom
she would say it's completely wrong
you know yeah yeah but i like the way i
take i like my dumplings like this i
think it's in my personal opinion better
right because it's to my palate right so
with korean dumplings there's a lot of
filling there's
a whole [ __ ] ton of chives a lot of
noodles you know
onions and everything else i produced
the amount of chives
by half i added less noodles um
i added the the squeezed out tofu but
then there's other [ __ ] that i put in
there that's not that's more typical to
like chinese dumplings right so like
hoisin and everything else and i like
the sweetness of it and i just adjusted
it to my own
and then the buddy must have what did
you put in i was like actually i don't
know let me see
i had to backtrack but at that point
it's because i know what these things
taste like because i
ate it so much i'm just gonna see what
happens exactly and so
the next time you have my dumplings it's
gonna taste a little different you know
and the third time it's gonna taste a
little different exactly because i'm
cooking at home yeah you know
and it shouldn't it shouldn't matter too
much right yeah especially right now
like it shouldn't matter at all right
now it really
doesn't matter at all right i'm not like
you look at my instagram feed now
it versus when it before before this
pandemic it's like
i'm just making sure i get through the
day
[Laughter]
so i can barely get i can barely get all
the ingredients that i want
i'm just gonna make it through the day
you know and just make sure my
girlfriend is fed
she's not angry and yeah this is it's
whatever we can do you know it's like
it's it's more like a survival mold
right now
it's not really about getting fancy or
anything i think what people don't get
to it's like um
i'll go to a a friend's house right they
go oh i don't really have a lot of
ingredients like i can't make a lot of
food i look in the fridge
you got a [ __ ] ton of stuff dude it's
not that you don't have ingredients it's
just you just
don't cook so you don't see the
potential in all this other right you
know yeah i think that's like
with me like everyone people always ask
me it's like i don't know what to cook
and
and then i think it's you just gotta
train your eyes you know you
gotta be able to open the fridge and get
to a point where like oh i know that
this and this and this will
get go well together right but for most
people they haven't
been cooking most of their lives and so
you know it's
it's they're not used to it right like
me as you know growing up i was a fat
kid growing up so
you know coming home from school like
you gotta figure a [ __ ] out
how do i make these like pizza bagels
taste better than just
throw them in the microwave yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you
it's like you train yourself over all
these years of like
manipulating ingredients until you you
you make sure it tastes
good right and so i think um if you're a
new cook starting out it's just like you
just gotta start
you just gotta start doing it mess up a
little bit it's okay if you make a
mistake right now
and then you just get better and better
at it and then soon you look at the
fridge and then you're like oh
i see it it's like you're like like neo
and you just start seeing
these things like it just comes
automatically to you yeah
yeah well so for you as a if you were to
give like somebody advice on
you know if they let's say they wanted
to get into cooking what is something
that you would tell them to do
that you probably would have done
differently just starting out
like getting into the career of the
industry yeah or just cooking in general
right because i think it's daunting for
a lot of people
if i if i ask somebody like oh you know
can you
i don't want to cook for you i was like
bro i'm not that great cook you know
first of all you know
like i think you just you're scared
about something like eve like even our
parents right nobody was sitting there
critiquing their [ __ ] food
right they just did it repetitiously so
often they just got better and better
and better
exactly you know that's the thing it's
cooking is just like learning anything
else
right it's really about taking that
first step
and just trying right and you gotta
be open to making mistakes you know and
you gotta be open to
learning from those mistakes and that's
all cooking really is
it's like the first time you ever cook
something you're probably going to burn
it or it's probably under seasoned
right but then it's a matter of you know
adjusting
right and so cooking to me it's all
about making all this like fine
tuning you know you're fine tuning
everything
um until you get it to the point where
it's almost perfect
right and there are there's like dishes
that i've worked on
like like kanji like i've made kanji
like
so many times in my life and i can
probably make it with my eyes closed
but there are things that i can still do
tomorrow if i make kanji
that is going to make it better than it
it was the last time i made kanji
right so a dish is you know food is
always
changing right yeah and you just got to
be able to be
used to be willing to just go and make
that first mistake
and then and then learn from it yeah so
i think that's the first step
you know for any home cook um if it's
like for somebody who wants to get into
the
industry i think he's got to find like
a good mentor you know you got to find
somebody that is going to
um i mean either you really commit
yourself and go to culinary school
or you find a kitchen that you know that
has a great chef that's going to mentor
you
and and guide you and teach you and let
you let you make mistakes
and then you learn from those mistakes
so again
the same thing you just got to try and
learn from all your mistakes along the
way
yeah i think the men i think that's what
i liked about
um kind of restaurants and chefs in like
japan
it's all by trade you know a lot of the
stuff that we like over there it's
this man was teaching you this they
didn't go to culinary school per se
you know but they're very good at that
one craft
like that kid who learns how to like i
don't know like jiro right yeah
like maybe not to that extent but i
didn't realize that um
like sushi making was a huge trade out
there it wasn't like you went to
culinary school and you learned how to
make sushi it was no you were that bus
boy
yeah you learn like everything for years
before you can move on to the next step
yeah right like in the movie like in
that documentary like the guy who's
making like
who was it the omelet oh yeah it's like
10 years
over and over and over and you know when
you get to
that level of cooking it's really about
that refinement right it's like
it it's really that 10 000 rule right
you do something
like 10 000 times or 10 000 hours before
you you master it right and that's what
it is with like sushi or
that level of cooking right you it's
repetitiveness right and so
in a fine dining restaurant you know
you're you're peeling
you know tomatoes or something or you're
you're peeling um
or you're making a certain dish or
preparing a certain ingredient
and you're doing like hundreds and
hundreds and thousands and thousands of
times
just to get it to where it's like um you
create this muscle memory
right and then you get this like perfect
dish that comes out of it afterwards
yeah yeah so but that's different that's
a whole different level yeah
a whole different level of cooking i
mean there's a lot to be uh
respected about when i was watching this
show uh
tara's house there was this one kid who
wanted to be a chef and then he was kind
of [ __ ] on chefs who only do one
thing for the rest of their life
and he wanted to be a chef that was like
he's like i don't understand how you oh
not just chefs just people in general
like who would do a craft one thing for
them and do it over and over and over he
was like i want to do a million things
and for me i'm not about that no i mean
definitely not right you can't do that
it's like you're
what are you gonna be good at yeah it's
like you're shitty at ten thousand
things a good job
you know right and so like it's
interesting like when i watch this stuff
too it's like
i wonder if that's how a lot of other
younger people think because he was
really young
you know and he has such a hard stance
on about
you know oh i can be great at everything
and i i don't think people
realize how finite life is like right
we're not going to be on this earth
forever
yeah you know you do have a limited
amount of time in what you do with it is
very [ __ ] important of course like if
i
for example if he wanted to be a chef
and he walked into a kitchen he goes
i can make ten thousand dishes really
well i'd like to see that
i'd really like to see that right you
know there's these italian chefs that
all they do is just make italian dishes
right you tell them to make a japanese
dish they go what the [ __ ] is that
exactly he wouldn't know what to do
exactly but that italian dish that they
make is
amazing home run yeah home run so
there's nothing wrong with that nothing
there's there's an art form to it right
i think there's a certain level of
um respect that i have for somebody who
can do something um
one thing specifically really really
well and they do it over and over and
over again that's really [ __ ] hard
yeah right like you know it's it's hard
to dedicate yourself
to that craftsmanship and you know
it's okay to go out there and like try a
million different things
yeah but ultimately you got to decide on
like a few things that you really want
to hone in on and and be good at
right and so especially in the kitchen
like you know you can't
you can't be great at everything yeah
it's almost impossible
i i wish too for a lot of people um
because of instagram
they would focus on i'm this is from
personal friends that i know when i come
over eat their food it's like
they do the best job of making their
food as pretty as possible
yeah and then when i eat the food i'm
like this doesn't taste like anything
what the [ __ ] were you doing
you know i'm glad it's pretty as [ __ ]
but it doesn't
taste good you know at the end of the
day we have to eat this food
right you could do all the little dots
and the flowers and [ __ ] that's fine you
learned you saw it on instagram
somewhere else
and then i eat the food i'm like you'd
insult the [ __ ] thing guys
you know where the [ __ ] is the salt and
i think that's what you were talking
about just the basics of things right
the technique
just seasoning things correctly you know
knowing how to grill things put these in
a pan braise things
right and i think those things are are
so overlooked because it's almost like
they
everybody wants the glory without
understanding the work that it takes to
get there
right and i'm tasting it on a lot of
these foods it's like even something as
simple as
oh this is this is the thing that blew
my mind there's restaurants
in japan specifically where a guy just
only does temperature
all he does is fry stuff yeah i'd be
surprised if he knew how to [ __ ] um
brave something you know but every dish
is fried yeah but when he fries it the
technique is so good
it's it's on another level right what
the [ __ ] why is this just so crispy
japan's on a different level
yeah but that kind of goes to show where
that technique is so important
right you know it's when you look at it
yeah it's just like this fried piece of
thing it's
it doesn't have like a flower or all
this you know [ __ ] right but when you
eat it's like holy [ __ ] this is amazing
it's like perfect
yeah yeah i've yet to go to japan i was
supposed to go to japan this year
oh [ __ ] yeah you would have loved it i
know i just
it's damn pandemics i was supposed to be
in vietnam for
three weeks uh this year too yeah and
then uh just gonna go eat everything out
there
specifically like places that you just
normally wouldn't go to because
i have a friend um who has a bunch of
family out there so they were just going
to take us around
oh yeah and i've heard so many good
things about vietnam and just amazing
food and yeah
just everything it's really cool yeah
and then uh one of my favorite food
experiences was taiwan like when i had
the
street food there i was like holy [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is all this yeah that's another
one too that's no one
on my list to go oh taiwan the street
food in taiwan is nuts man like
i've heard so many good things about it
like when i went on these food tours and
they were taking me to fancy restaurants
i was like i want to get out of here and
go to the street
i think it's good right but it's missing
something yeah that the street food has
yeah and goes back to this person has
been making guava
for their whole life right that's all
they do yeah they will not [ __ ] it up
you know and uh that's one of the most
like just small [ __ ] too like i remember
i had this quaba place and there's a
place that does that oyster pancake like
i think it's called elijah or something
like that
and i can't find that here and it makes
me sad
because after i came back to la i was
like somebody has to do this well in
you know in los angeles there's
taiwanese people here yeah i
they don't do it nobody knows that yeah
yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] man so now
i'm just sitting here like i'm not gonna
have until i go back to taiwan yeah
you know food is weird like it kind of
takes you into this place where that's
why i always
tell people food is more than just just
eating something good
right you know what i mean it's this
whole experience it's just
you get to connect to the culture i
don't know something about it like when
i go to a country the first thing i want
to do is eat the food
right yeah um it's the exact same way i
think yeah it's the best way to
experience the culture of the
of the country that you're visiting it's
just through the food and through the
people
yeah so especially the places that you
can get like really really good cheap
food on the street and then you can also
experience like really high-end food
like japan has like really probably
really cheap food you can go to 7-eleven
and get
a nice sandwich and then you can also
get really expensive sushi same thing
with like hong kong like you can get
really cheap like
food out of a side of the street and
then also they have these amazing like
three michelin star restaurants in there
too so there's like this whole spectrum
right
and so i love these cities where you can
just go in and and
try a little piece of everything yeah
and so every time i every time i go i
travel
like my girlfriend hates it but i'll all
eat like
three lunches and two dinners
it's like i have a limit i don't live
here i have to eat this i
absolutely have to yeah i tell her it's
for research
it really is though i get excited when
like chefs go to another country and
they come back and they bring a little
bit back
yeah because you wouldn't have had that
epiphany or the experience
unless you went there right because
you're trying to replicate something or
yeah kind of replicate what you the
experience versus mainly the taste it's
like that
what i experienced in this bite here i
want to bring back right and have
somebody else
experience that exactly like that that
was that's that's exactly the case when
i went to hong kong a few years ago
and i was in search of this like this
ham
and this ham is called jinwa ham
and so it's supposed to be like one of
the best hams you can get
in in like chinese cuisine it's usually
used for making like
exo sauce and it's very fragrant
so you know it's also um it was it i
would compare it to and you smell it it
smells like
a barrical hammer ooh okay right like
when you you take a sniff of it it's
like funky
yeah and so um when i was in hong kong a
few years ago i saw one
like usually you'll see one in stores
they already cut up but i saw one just
hanging
like a whole leg yeah and i just saw i
was like i gotta have it
[Laughter]
so i just like bought it on a whim i
didn't even think about how i'm gonna
get this back to america
yeah i just bought it and then so i had
it and i was like i was like shoot i'm
gonna get this home
because you can't like put in your
luggage yeah they're gonna confiscate it
when you get back
so me and my uncle devise a plan and
he's like okay let's go to the
the post office we'll we'll like cover
really nice and stuff it with a bunch of
other stuff and then dogs won't sniff it
yeah things and then we shipped it back
to the us
um and luckily no one did customs in and
confiscated
um but this ham is amazing like it's
like it's funky and smell
used a lot of times in like chinese
soups or like i said exo sauce and
it's so fragrant and it's
yeah it it tastes like a little bit it's
a little saltier but it tastes like a
barrical ham oh wow
yeah so damn dude you [ __ ] smuggled
up i smuggled the whole leg up
it's like i was like i'm gonna get that
[ __ ] i need it immediately yeah
like my girlfriend bought like these
nice shoes like for 300 bucks in hong
kong i bought a 300
ham how about the hem last year i
i still have it in fact it's it's in
my i can't fit in my freezer so it's in
one of my friend's freezers right now
that's [ __ ] funny dude that's
hilarious
yeah dude i mean when you have like
these specific ingredients it can change
up a whole dish
you know and those are one of those
things that you have exactly
oh you know there's something special
about this right i hate it when i taste
something i'm like
this is so good what the [ __ ] is in it
and i can't i can't pinpoint it
and then you'll ask them that i can't
tell you i'm like well [ __ ] you guy
i'm like [ __ ] you i don't i want to try
to recreate it somehow
but there's always something special
about it and there's always that that
special ingredient
and it's it's not a [ __ ] ton of stuff
but it's that one thing again it comes
down to just
less stuff and really about the quality
of a couple good ingredients
you know and that ham i had to have it
i mean that's i i think some of my
favorite italian restaurants just do
that too
right it's just good pasta good sauce
and then you ask them what the spell is
like no we just we have really good
pasta that we make
and that's the biggest difference i'm
like even when i try to make pasta home
like
it tastes like ass like what the [ __ ]
why doesn't it taste like their pasta
you know
right i don't know i can't figure it out
but i just i have to work as a [ __ ]
busboy there and then figure it out
myself
you know when you uh do you do you i
mean you were talking about wanting to
open a restaurant
you know you know pre pandemic right uh
are you thinking about going into the
restaurant
industry that way again gosh
it's so hard to say right now yeah right
it's
because it's scary it's a scary world
for our industry
you know we don't know what's going to
happen next and
i i i want to be a very optimistic
um but when people tell me they want to
open a restaurant right now
during a pandemic i just i'm just
thinking to myself why
why do you really first of all do you
even know how hard it is running a
restaurant
when there isn't a pandemic yeah
right now you gotta have to have all
these other health like
health precautions in in place so for me
it's like
it may not be a traditional restaurant
per se like you're
you're sit down and like you have it you
know you have waiters and everything
that used to be the case used to be the
dream i think now
it's more so about um
how can i make a something that is
accessible for everybody
um that is you know that also
you know um fits the mold the future
i've been thinking a lot about like
ghost kitchens um
right like i've also been thinking about
like
just maybe doing like a really good
burger out of a ghost kitchen
right i've had thoughts about that and
i've had thoughts about opening up a
softer
place yeah yeah um you know just
something simple like i just
want to do something that is because
right now it's it's so
unsure right like the world is so unsure
about like
it's an actual sit-down restaurant okay
if it was if there was no pandemic yeah
i would definitely
put together a sit-down restaurant but
right now with all this going on and
and the way that our our industry is
going to change
right yeah i think that it needs to be
something that's really casual
i think people are you know they they
now want to be at home and
they don't mind ordering and getting
takeout you know i think that
that's a huge model that it
should be capitalized on i think i i
would like to be able to
you know get into that that market
somehow i think i started really
enjoying
um fast casual food lately
um especially because a lot of the fast
casual spots the food is like very
whatever you know but
i always look at the stuff that they're
serving i'm like you could do this so
much better
you know yeah like you really could it's
but they're not open you know and the
only spots that i have left over are
like such
places i don't want to eat at i'm like
how come you guys can't just do it a
little better
i would like for like i was just talking
about the hat right the hat's one of
those places that does something really
well like i really like more of those
spots
you know where it's it's fast it's it's
really quick food but they do it
really [ __ ] well yeah and i like
some of those restaurants they're all
sit down and i'm like you could do
something fast
you know just do it you know yeah and i
mean
i think fast casual is a good way to go
right now i think just people
um are they they see how easy it is to
just order something on ubereats and
they can get it and deliver it to them
and
you know it's a good i guess it's a good
business model to get into it's also
very
like low overhead to kind of get into
that model versus opening up an actual
like brick and mortar
and you have to hire all these people
the staffing is huge man
just front house management back-end
kitchen management you know just waiters
bus boys everything else i'm like
where where do you guys profit i'm like
where does the money where's the money
you know yeah it's like labor cost is
like
your biggest one of your biggest costs
yeah right like just having all these
all these people around you know i i i
i can't wait for the days when they're
like you can actually have more robots
in the kitchen
or they could just do the more like
monotonous thing that you don't have to
do
yeah you know at dodger stadium they
have like two robots like frying fries
and
what yeah really yeah what the [ __ ]
that's nuts
yeah they have two robots that do like i
think they do the corn dogs and they do
fries
dude [ __ ] andrew yang was right dude
it's automation dude yeah like but no
for reals like
in our industry like that's the scary
thing right like we have so many cooks
that have been doing this repetitive
tasks
that are soon gonna be replaced by
robots in the next five to ten years
yeah
right and so i tell a lot of my cooks
like dude you gotta like
learn something else right you gotta
like get better every single day because
these robots are gonna catch up to you
they're gonna replace you in five ten
years
like they're there's like cooks in
kitchens like all throughout la have
been doing the same
exact thing for like 10 15
20 years oh wow and guess what in the
next five or ten years they're going to
be all
out of a job because it's too expensive
to pay for you
i can just get a robot to chop
vegetables instead
you know that robot can't sue your ass
they don't come in with an attitude yeah
they're never late
[Laughter]
they're always timely on time perfect
every fundament never call out sick
i know so i'm telling you man like it's
like the food industry always changes
but
like the biggest changes have been
happening happening lately and those
adjustments are
are hard it's it's very difficult and
like um
i think because we do drinks and stuff
it's a lot easier on my end you know
people have asked like aren't you going
to open up a restaurant i was like i
will only do a restaurant
if i do back-end stuff right like i can
you know brand and market and everything
else like that but in terms of me
working inside a kitchen are you [ __ ]
nuts
like i that's why i respect chefs and
cooks so much because
i can see the chaos you know and somehow
and that's why i get really upset
sometimes when people
they they treat these food workers as if
why did you get it perfect every time
it's like do you know how hard that is
yeah
you know it's [ __ ] difficult yeah you
know like give people a little bit of
grace
send your dish back and have it come
back and they'll work on it for you you
know and
sometimes these yelp reviews are so
severe and harsh and i'm like if you
only understood what was like to work at
a kitchen
you would understand that you're a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] raging [ __ ] yeah you
know yeah most people just have never
walked in those shoes and it's no idea
how hard it is on a day-to-day basis
i mean you know especially right now
it's like you know how dare you like not
you know how dare you send anything back
it's like these guys are barely making
it right now
you know especially for every restaurant
that's out there it's like they're
they're they're like you know it's
they're hanging by a thread
yeah you know just skinning their teeth
just trying to make it through the next
day
and so it's it's it it makes me so
furious when i
when i see people like complain about
you know their food or anything like
that and it's like do you have no idea
i don't know how you guys got it every
time but when you were working at luxon
the thing that i always got was your
guys's version of like broccoli beef
and the steak was perfect every [ __ ]
time how the [ __ ] did you guys serve
that [ __ ]
exactly how it was supposed to be and
and there was no gray ring everywhere
anywhere i'm like what the [ __ ] what
happened here how did you do this
technique you son of a [ __ ] i'm like i
can't cook this like this
you know that was actually one of my
favorite things it was like i i liked it
because
you know when somebody tries to either
like reconstruct a very
familiar dish i think like nine times
out of ten i'm like just give me the
regular dish
but when i had that broccoli beef i was
like this is [ __ ] good dude
i love that dish it was so amazing that
this is the classic on there
yeah it was like they had an exo sauce
with it and also
it's a uh he called it a black bean ghee
so it was like you know a black bean
sauce with like
chilies and chili oil and then like
clarified butter oh yeah it was so
[ __ ] good dude
i think i went there for we went there
for an anniversary and then it was like
her birthday after that i was like
let's just go back so there were
definitely some
some definitely hits on there that we
people would just come back for all the
time that's why i didn't listen to a lot
of these reviews sometimes because like
lux shot i think had like three and a
half stars right and then
yeah it was three and a half stars
mostly because of i think was their
servers or something
yeah i was like the [ __ ] are you talking
about this place is
amazing like i never ate anything that i
disliked i was like this place is
[ __ ] dope
and we would keep going back but i
remember friends like odds three and a
half i was like but you gotta
you gotta give these restaurants a
chance yeah like you can't live and die
always buy these yelp reviews right give
it a go and see what happens if you're
interested try it
yeah you know i tell my girlfriend that
exact exact same thing like you can't
look at your help for like
recommendations you know just yeah
just go and just try it you know and and
a lot of times yelp reviews aren't even
true yeah like it's like a 50 50 chance
like um
i forgot i'm blinking on this restaurant
but i read the reviews and
i was like huh but i'm looking at the
food i'm like that looks pretty [ __ ]
good
you know went there it was like a taco
shop right and i was like this is
[ __ ] good i don't know what you're
talking about i understand it because
they're talking about their service or
something bad happened during the day
i'm like
i'm asking about the food here yeah
is the food good yes or no you know i
don't care what happened about you and
your [ __ ] dog that day like
what what happened with the food the
like the food was delicious but this
cereal i don't give a [ __ ] moving on
you know i personally don't care i
remember when like yelp first came out
and like all these chinese restaurants
we all get like really bad reviews
not because of the food but because of
the service it's like
you should expect that right you should
expect that from a chinese restaurant i
would have a terrible service reviews on
these like my favorite vietnamese
restaurants like that person had
their thumb in my soup i was like that
play was good
i was like that's the one i'm going to
this place had to be well the bees are
the best
i was like it has an a for cleansing
this [ __ ] that restaurant
yeah too much time they're not busy
enough no i need a couple of cockroaches
here and there
i need the uh the [ __ ] floor mat to
be a piece of cardboard yeah
that's what i [ __ ] like like that's
my favorite
like vietnamese restaurants too it's
like when i walk in and it smells a
little bit like chlorine
and bleach i go into the bathroom the
[ __ ] mop and the buckets in there and
i'm like
this is going to be a delicious meal i
can already i think it was
ali wong that made that joke like you
you know you're
you're in a good vietnamese restaurant
you walk into the bathroom and you see
like
the mop closet in there
the mop closet and it always smells a
little bit like [ __ ] bleach or some
[ __ ] and i'm like
they only mix like bleach and water and
they clean everything with it and i'm
like oh this
this vietnamese restaurant is gonna be
the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i already know man
and it's those are those like
mom-and-pop stores exactly you know and
i
so sad now that you made me think like
oh these restaurants might actually
disappear and i might be left with these
[ __ ] cheese pull restaurants only
i'm like son of a [ __ ] these people
better inherit these restaurants man
yeah i mean i was listening to
david chang and he was talking about how
like yeah a lot of these mom and pops
are probably gonna disappear and we're
gonna be stuck with like
restaurants like applebee's and and uh
all these other chains oh i'll be so
[ __ ] sick it's like you think about
it like these are the chains of the ones
are getting their ass is saved
mm-hmm right the mom and pops aren't
getting their ass to save their you know
they're
the government's not helping them out
right they're literally like i said
they're
they're hanging by a thread you're
trying to make ends meet trying to make
it through the next day
you know and it's like these other chain
restaurants
they're gonna be around yeah they're
they're owned by these large rich people
yeah so it's the mom and pop that need
her help
oh man people i i've been i always say
this to myself i'm go
uh i'm gonna support restaurants i'm
just gonna order every everything this
week
it's not really for them it's for me and
i'm just like gaining an absorbent
amount of weight right because i'm
telling myself i'm being a good person
i was like i was a really good person i
ate out four times today right
yeah like one of my favorite restaurants
um what we talked about was causing pie
you know that little brunch place like
i go there so often but even then they
were struggling yeah and then one of the
more popular restaurants in the south
pass area
you know people don't understand to to
have somebody bake everything that you
eat in there
there's the labor cost is high right you
know and they're just like oh this place
is so good
and i'm like that takes [ __ ] a lot of
heart and effort to make that
[ __ ] yeah like most people don't realize
that you have
30 to 35 percent of food cost right you
know
you're a really good restaurant you're
under 30 percent most restaurants is
like 30 35 percent
and then you have like another um 35 to
40
in labor cost right and then you have
your overhead and so your
your profit margin is like five percent
you know
[ __ ] it's like it's like a tiny little
piece like you can profit off of
right and so if these restaurants right
now they aren't packed right and they
they're designed to profit when they're
packed um
right that's the business model that's
the only way that they were that's when
they when they
both plans up and everything like okay
we're gonna be successful if we're gonna
be
have this x amount of people come in
every single day
right well now they don't have that
coming in right so now that their profit
margin is completely slashed and so
they're hanging
they're just hanging you know trying to
make it by so
it's it's i was explaining this to a
buddy of mine in uh
one of these restaurants we're doing
well he goes well how they're not doing
well their their [ __ ] dishes are like
12 each and it's like bro shut up
you don't know what it takes to make
that dish that you enjoy
exactly you know there's there's so much
more to it and i wish people would
really understand
that it would it would make you give i
would just have a little bit of empathy
you know right just a little bit just
for these people that actually if you're
ordering out right now like on those
apps like postmates and uber dude they
take
everything they take everything from you
like they charge 30
yeah you know that's that's you got
nothing left after that
100 because you know we have shrimp
daddy and everything else and
you know you guys ordered from that is
cool you know we're we're able to we're
keeping that open so we could pay our
staff and we're you know we're doing
okay but
all that profit's gone by the time it
comes to you exactly and we're just
doing it because
we want to feed people right people have
no idea like you know
where the numbers go right they have no
idea how expensive
it is to like make food and that's
another thing when people like think
about opening a restaurant they don't
they don't realize like how little money
you can make
off off this business right and so it's
um
it's you know again they romanticize you
know what it is to be
to have a restaurant to own a business
you know they think it's an american
dream but yeah
you know you gotta you gotta have some
grit to be able to survive some you know
the
the rough times especially right now
yeah aft after drip
swirls closed down one of the partners
you know he was asking me he goes well
there's a partner that i you know he was
the one that i
we were still on good terms so he goes
well let's take that small spot and
you know start doing food in there and
i'm like i don't think you understand
how difficult that is we had soft serve
right we did this
yeah you know i've seen that space
there's no way you can do food out there
there's no way you can put any burner
back there
that was no possibility i was like what
would we serve man
just have three air fryers in there try
to do what are we gonna do here you know
like the most thing that we would be
able to do is like cold sandwiches i
guess
right you know but we would still need a
prep kitchen exactly
and that's going to cut into a huge part
of our cost so it's like
saucer made the most sense soft serve is
the only thing that made sense there
you know and it was great it did well
people loved it i missed that [ __ ] till
this day man like i
i had so many plans for it it's one of
those things where i look i don't regret
it but it's more like
uh like koreans like akko i was like um
what a waste what shame
you know i saw the potential that was
there yeah and
yeah it's a shame when you when you get
into business with people that just
don't
get the business yeah the business side
is the part that people
always forget you know like at the end
of the day yeah cooking is a passion
cooking is an art but you have to make
money to keep it alive
you know you and i think one of the
hardest things that i don't know if you
ever want this when you were probably
like a younger chef but
criticism and critique was something
that a lot of people can't take right
you know it's it's hard it feels like a
personal attack right
but when you have a business when things
don't go well or things aren't selling
right it's not an attack on you
as a chef as a person it's more like i
have
staff that i need to pay and i make sure
i need to make sure they walk away with
a paycheck yeah because that's my worry
every time
it's not even about me it's about the
staff it's like [ __ ] like these people
work here
right my business goes down they don't
make money and it makes me nervous
you know yeah i think being a business
owner is
that's like one of the the stresses that
you get to take on
and it's like most people don't know
they don't understand that
yeah you know they never ran a business
and so it's like
it's tough it's really tough in a in a
restaurant setting
so you get just got to have that grit
you know and it's like
passion only gets you so far yeah right
like you know for me it's like
um as i get older it's like you know
this
the food that i create yeah i'm
passionate about it but you know some
days
i'm not very passionate about it right
some days i really don't
want to even be in the kitchen right and
so um and i think
you know your the your grit like your
determination and your
your work ethic really gets you through
those those days
of like i actually want to be there yeah
yeah yeah
so i mean you wanted to open up a softer
spot
yeah what would what would your plans be
for a software place what my plans being
just i mean
for a soft-serve spot like the thing is
for a chef you don't really need to be
there right i think it's just like
creating an r d part yeah you just
create the system
you know you create a system for how
they should function
the formulas for like the recipes for
the soft serve
got a couple of machines you hire some
good people and
that thing should pretty much run itself
at that point like you think
you would think from a man who said he
ran
a kitchen with like 200 people you [ __ ]
face i hope you're dead
yeah so i mean like you hire good people
i think that's
that's the key point right you hire good
people yeah i [ __ ] up
if you have a good system if you have a
good system in place you're the right
person to run that system you should be
able that business should run
yeah right and like soft serve has such
a great profit margin
you know and you can like again it's
just like y'all
as a chef all you got to do is make sure
you get the recipes and the systems in
place and
hire some good people and then check on
it every once in a while you don't even
be there like 24 7.
right and it's like it's a great i think
it's a great business model
you know i thought too
i man it's funny because i missed that
spot because i used to go there and like
i want
i want some soft surface i would go
there and eat and i'm like it's not
there anymore like i love soft serve
like there's not enough softer places in
l.a
for sure man i'm telling you like soft
soft serve makes me happy dude it's one
of those things like i
i still go to mcdonald's only for the
software i'll go there and i'll get a
dollar cone
for the drive through and i'm out like i
look at somisomi
right like they're everywhere right like
that they just
blew up like people love soft serve i
mean i hate looking at it now because
everyone has it and everyone's like just
like so about it but
it it's you can it just shows you like
it can it can succeed in a lot of
different markets
and the thing is with ice cream
everybody loves ice cream yeah who
doesn't
right like if you don't like the ice
cream like there's something wrong with
you but
there's like there's there's definitely
a market for it right
even the neighborhood i live in now i
live in like west adams in l.a
and like there's this like up and coming
area
in la and there's a lot of cool trendy
restaurants coming in but there's no
like good burger shop and there's no
ice cream shop right the staples
the staples are like that you should
have in like every neighborhood
right and so i'm like i'm like planning
i'm like thinking about it and like
is it is now the time to pull you know
pull the trigger and like open up a soft
spot right so i mean software spots are
are also i think it's um what's the word
i'm looking for uh
pandemic resistance you know it's
anything resistant yeah they come in you
get your sausage and you're out either
way yeah
like pre-covered or not that's how it
was done right and so
you know when when covet happened i was
like [ __ ]
like you know i'm like please if it was
just there
it was doing so well and what i liked
about the place too was just
we only had four flavors there wasn't
much right you know four flavors and
people
enjoyed it for what it was we didn't
have an absorbent amount of toppings or
anything else like that right
it was oh these are the flavors this is
how it is um
you can make small modifications but
because we didn't allow you to put 30
toppings people got their stuff in and
out fast yeah
faster than any other software spot out
there hands down right you know
it's like i know that it tastes good
like this
so this is what you're gonna get if you
don't like it that's okay yeah
like when i first saw it come about like
i was like that's a good idea that's a
good spot
that's low overhead but then i was like
well hope the person running it's gonna
do a good job and it did not happen
[ __ ] again high and [ __ ] again
[ __ ] coming going to edc during the
time like it was like it was ridiculous
went to edc came back with [ __ ]
sunglasses and shades and beads around
his [ __ ] neck
but all the employees there i'm like you
are an [ __ ]
like how dare you i mean you can do that
if you have the right systems in place
right for sure right like you know if it
was me like i could
set it up where i don't have to be there
like i think it's it comes down to again
a good
like manager or somebody who knows how
to build systems
right and make sure it functions without
it functions with the right people yeah
right and and
again it's just down to those those
basic awesome business
things the [ __ ] told me he knew
how to do it he lied to me
he both lied to me [ __ ] said i
ran to a kitchen with 200 people
soft serve easy this full broke down
i remember uh we had this the the
[ __ ] the nozzle
just for the cold brew he lied to me
about that i was like come on bro
i know what [ __ ] uh like cold brew is
supposed to be like
this nitro cold brew the the biggest
part of nitro cobra that i personally
enjoy is the froth
yeah you know that's that creaminess
that i enjoy he goes oh we can't do with
this i'm like
bro get the [ __ ] out of here with this
[ __ ] looked it up i was like your shit's
all [ __ ] up i did one google search
you know and lo and behold you confront
somebody like that they just start
stuttering
like a madman like oh i was oh i'm like
oh god you are a habitual liar i had no
[ __ ] idea
yeah my fault though i always uh my my
biggest curse is that i i tend to
gravitate towards a lot of artists
you know because i think what they
create is amazing i will never knock
that dude that he never made good food
like it should taste
great yeah but that's literally
ten percent of it for the in the
restaurant industry right
it's so small you know i didn't know
that and that was my fault
and i thought and i kind of trusted my i
trusted them to do stuff that they
said they knew how to do and um when you
have somebody like me
who's very curious who wants to learn
and
they just didn't know what to do they
thought i was problematic i'm like oh
because you're
stealing and i'm asking you where the
money went you know right
so you know for me like i i definitely
learned a lot though so it was it was a
good learning experience it was
it was a crash course and and uh even
how small it was in the
like food industry was that your that
was your first like that was my very
first one
all right and then took those lessons
and brought it over to two three other
concepts so it's like yeah
oh and now i know a little better i was
like oh
okay again it goes back to what we're
talking about earlier just learning from
your mistakes
what a [ __ ] two-year mistake huh that
[ __ ] was
that [ __ ] was long man right it was very
very long and
and i and i definitely enjoyed what i
liked about the most was when people
come in and they enjoyed the food and i
think that's what i was kind of
surviving off of was
having people come and they go i love
the soft serve and it makes me feel so
good
you know it was it was like a drug
almost it was like damn and when people
didn't like it it didn't make me angry
it made me
upset that i didn't get to give them
something that i that i felt when i had
a soft serve
right so it's weird like food i have a
weird relationship with food i just want
people to be happy with what they eat
you know yeah
i think i think you're you're a chef at
heart you know i think
everybody you just want people to be
happy with the food that you're gonna
you know you just want to feed people
right you just want to make sure
they feel good after they leave is it
about that dude what is it like it's
just it's like a weird joy
you know like i don't know it makes me
smile
i have the same feeling that's why i
became a chef you know like
when i was a kid or in high school i
used to like have i used to make food
and my friends would taste it and they
enjoyed it that's why i got into it you
know so
um this is in us you know i think
you know it's people that love food want
or
just want to take care of people you
know that's part about feeding others
it's like you're
when you're it's like when you're uh
like growing up chinese like
our way our way are the way our parents
said i love you
is like have you eaten yet right you
know
and so that was that's the same way for
me it's like
me feeding people is my way of like
showing
this person love right my way of showing
affection
right if i spend a lot of time preparing
this meal
you know it's it's my way of showing
them that i care about them
you know i want to make sure that you're
well nourished right
so yeah i think that that's probably a
huge thing about you my mom used to say
uh i get full when i see you guys eat
you know it's like watching somebody
enjoy a meal kind of satisfies
them for some reason you know and that
was the same feeling when somebody had
this officer they eat it and they go oh
this i can't wait to come back
i'm like damn i don't know why that
makes me feel awesome you know it's like
i
i gave them something that it's like
we're almost sharing uh us
we're sharing a similar experience
without any words yeah you know it's
just
i could share happiness with you it's
weird you know
i missed that place i missed it so much
it was it was it was so fun
let's open the softer spot dude you let
me [ __ ] know
you let me know bro anything you touch
i'm down to do it like
honestly one of the biggest things like
especially when i started cooking food
was when
um when you when i met you guys at
little meats right and i've always loved
eating food
especially as a fat [ __ ] like i just eat
all the time you know but i didn't also
i didn't also realize how important it
was for you to know how to cook
in order for you to also enjoy food more
and you know watching you guys cook
and watching you guys do this especially
because you guys were already working
and you did this on your spare time
i can't even believe how i did that i
don't know how you did it either dude
i was like i was already working like 60
hours i worked i worked literally
six days a week and then on my off day
i did little meets on a sunday you're
[ __ ]
nuts dude when i was watching you guys
work right and you know robin told me
hey this he's working all the time and
this is his spare time i'm like this
[ __ ] maniac like
how does he have a personal life you
know but but watching
how you guys would just serve and just
develop that relationship with food was
something that i was missing because i
didn't cook
you know yeah i cook at home here and
there and it was something fun but i
never really took the time to understand
how difficult it was to make these
dishes that i enjoyed and when i started
trying to do it myself and i was [ __ ]
up consistently i didn't know how to
cook a steak until i met you
yeah really right no [ __ ] i knew how to
like cook
very specific dishes that i knew how to
do well that i learned from my mom or
something else but
in terms of making more than five or six
dishes no i would look i had the same
problem i would look into a fridge and
say there's no food here
yeah but now i'm like there's a bunch of
veggies i could do something with this
fry it up put into a fried rice make a
good um like a soup or a [ __ ] with it
i can figure it out i know my wheelhouse
now yeah i didn't have that before when
i met you you know mm-hmm
so it's again it's just people just need
to get in get in the kitchen it's just
like
you know if you love to if you love food
then it should be a
easy transition to get in the kitchen
and just try something right
you know and so it's you can't be afraid
to just
make a mistake and i think that's holds
a lot of people back
they're so fearful of making mistakes
yeah yeah
like even something small too like
appreciating
like how to make good eggs you know and
i was like this is a little more
difficult than i thought it was
you know i'm like over here going to a
restaurant i didn't make my eggs right
and i'm like i'm making at home like
i didn't make things right you know i'm
like oh [ __ ]
how come their scrambled egg is so much
better than mine right you know and i'm
like watching them cook it i'm like
oh that's a little more involved than i
expected out of scrambled eggs right
you know i remember my girlfriend when
we first started dating like her eggs
were okay and then finally taught her
how to make like
nice soft like silky french style like
scrambled eggs yeah
now she gets it every single time so
it's so
my [ __ ] fiance is so weird so you
know with eggs i always had like a
gratuitous amount of butter
right and you just shake up the pan you
get those curdles and it starts this
little soft scrambled egg she hates it
like that really she likes it denny's
style hard as [ __ ]
and she goes these eggs aren't cooked
enough i will [ __ ] stab you right now
you know she wants it this this hard
brick of eggs i think it's cause what
she grew up with right
so that's how she likes it yeah and so
whenever i make my eggs
i have to make her eggs separately
because she she wants it
cooked all the way through dry spots
that's the thing with eggs though
people like them the specific way yeah
it's like there's like a hundred
different ways to cook an egg and just
over easy sunny side yeah everybody
wants them
all different yeah so one of my favorite
ways to cook eggs is in that
[ __ ] the asian style and just oil and
you just fry the [ __ ] it's like deep
frying a [ __ ] egg
and i didn't know how to do it until i
saw it at a thai restaurant where i was
looking at the back i'm like
so that's how they do it it's like a
[ __ ] kind of [ __ ] oil you know
literally fry it and they literally deep
fry that [ __ ] and they toss
oil on top of it and i was like what the
[ __ ] i had no idea
nobody told me the tricks of the [ __ ]
trade yeah you know it's awesome though
yeah yeah man well uh that wraps up this
episode the podcast man
i hope everybody uh enjoyed this food
talk
i know there's a lot of people out there
who want to open up restaurants and
you know kind of get into the food space
but it's definitely something that's a
lot more involved than a lot of people
think
and i think just from this conversation
alone what i'm thinking is just start
with that passion first and be willing
to learn and make mistakes
right absolutely cool yeah so where can
they find you man
um i'm on instagram uh matt ewan cooks
spell m-a-t-t-y-u-e-n i keep doing those
[ __ ] cooking videos i'm always
waiting for them are you
yeah i like it because it's so simple
and straightforward i'm like
oh [ __ ] this is dope yeah i will
definitely post more especially because
i like that you make the food out of
just stuff that you have
right it's not like you went out to the
to the grocery store to create this very
specific
dish it's like this is what i have i'm
going to make something really good out
of it right
i'll definitely do more make sure that
you do more because i'm putting it out
there that you will
so people are going to see this all
right cool well guys uh genius brain
podcast every thursday and sundays
and we will see you guys next time peace